is called on the convergence of monte
carlo methods with stochastic grades so
please change and take care of it thanks
thank you yeah thank you so it's my
great pleasure to be here
uh so it's a wonderful workshop a lot of
free talks
so in this talk i'm gonna talk about the
converging analysis of monte carlo
method uh with the kai's ingredients
so this talk is based on the uh junk
work with my student defenso and my uh
former pd student panshi uh he's in our
postside contact and i will join the
bell stats department at the duke
so we've seen a lot of sampling problems
in this workshop
the goal of something is to generate a
sample from some targeted distribution
and the world something problem we've
seen a lot in this workshop is called
something from the uh log concave
distribution where the target diffusion
can be represented by this gibbs
diffusion
e to the power of minus of f of x
and this f
of x is uh could be strongly convex and
smooth so i will talk about the
assumptions later
and
one of the applications of sampling from
law concave diffusion is in large scale
basic learning
so suppose we have a
set of
data
observations vi from 1 to n
which is a draw from some uh online data
diffusion and we want to do uh bayesian
influence uh to calculate the posterior
or to sample from
posterior
which is proportional to the product of
the electrode function defined on the
div side
and the prior distribution p of x
and with some uh
mean algebra we can easily show that the
target between pi here
can be uh written as e to the power of
minus uh f of x where this f of x is the
summation of
n uh individual functions uh f1 to fn so
each fi here is just the
negative uh log density
uh
of uh each of the sufficient minus uh
some
log density or prime distribution
okay so this is a
one particular application of
something from a log concave
distribution
and in order to do that there are a lot
of mcmc method that we can using
so for most of them
we can describe them
in the following very
generic form
so it is a iterative
numerical algorithm
uh given some initial sample let's say
x0 we keep generating new samples from
the current example for example suppose
the current sample is x t
we generate x t plus one by uh randomly
perturbing the current sample or your
sample sum diffusion which is defined
based on the current sample and the
pipes also the underlying diffusion
function that's why i use this g sub f
of x t
to mean that this random vector can
depend on both x t
and also
the function the negative log density
function
and once we have the new sample xt plus
one we can uh accept it or we can reject
it with certain probability and this
probability
is also defined based on the current
sample the new sample and also uh the
underlying uh
hybrid distribution
okay
and the examples of mcmc neither that
can be uh described under this framework
include for example uh landing work
metropolis
boardwalk
mala and hmc and many others so we've
seen a great talk by
santosh yesterday which is
discuss different kind of
something nicer and many of them can be
unified under this uh generic
description
and in my talk i will be
focusing on two particular
mcm same method one is
hmc the homotonium and carlo the other
is underdamped uh landing van
dynamics
so for hmc
we know uh we first write down the
hamiltonian energy function and then we
solve the following uh system of
differential equations then we will have
the uh the solution to this uh system
ordinary differential equation will give
you uh two uh markov uh process xt and
vt
so here x
is the the position and the p is the
velocity okay so by doing this kind of
integration you can calculate the
idealized uh hmc uh dynamic although
this is not the algorithm we're using
but in the converging analysis we highly
uh rely on the connection between the
the discrete time hours and this
continued time uh dynamic
and the nice property about
hmc says if you uh
can solve this dynamic exactly then we
can prove that when t go to infinity the
marginal distribution of the position uh
prime into x t will convert to
some
distribution which is a marginal
distribution of
which is a targeted distribution
and another very related uh mcmc measure
is underdone the landing volume dynamics
which is described by the following
uh two differential equations the first
one is a stochastic differential
equation uh this is the the free shrink
turn the potential and also the brownian
motion
and the second one is just the ordinary
differential equation
and if you remove the friction turn as
well as the
boronian motion can actually
uh it will reduce to
some
differential equation which is very
similar to
hmc but it doesn't mean uh hmc is uh uh
simpler than under the landing fund in
terms of analysis
and similarly we can also calculate the
idealized or continuous time on the
damped landing fan dynamic
by doing this kind of
exact
integration
okay
here's a question we need to think about
when we apply this hmc or underdamped
landing fine to the real uh something
problems for example a large scale basic
learning problem i just described
a few
minutes ago
you know in order to apply hmc and the
underdamped landing fine because both of
them are gradient-based uh
mcms signatures we need to calculate the
gradient
but when the data set is very
large for example n is a number of
observations is very big
calculating the gradient the full
gradient will be very
expensive computationally or even
intractable okay and in order to
overcome this problem a very natural
idea is to use the cast gradient to
approximate the full gradient
and this gives rise to uh statistical
gradient flourishing of
hmc and the
underdamped landing pad okay and the key
question i want to
discuss in this talk is how to prove
the convergence of uh hmc and
underdamped landing fund with the kaiser
gradient estimators so when i see uh
stochastic gradient estimators
it is a very broad
family of the test gradient
estimators including for example mini
batch uh staycat gradient or furnace
reduced uh stochastic gradient so it's a
family of uh great statewide estimator
it's not just a mini batch uh
gradient
okay
so here is a
algorithm uh when you uh replace the
gradient by stochastic gradient in the
very standard hmc algorithm okay so this
algorithm uh has two uh
loops the inner loop is doing this uh uh
leapfrog uh numerical uh integration
and the other group you just keep
generating uh the random for example uh
velocity and from the current sample x t
you do this
uh leapfrog numerical integration for
uh let's say k number of uh times and
then you assign the
uh the generated qk to be the next uh xt
plus one okay so there are two uh index
uh the auto is indexed by t the inner
loop is indexed by k okay
and we don't do uh metropolis hasting
here because you know we want to avoid
the
calculation of a full gradient
also the calculation of the exact
function value because when you
calculate the function value you also
need to calculate the function value for
each fi which might also be time
consuming
okay
and in order to prove the
non-symptomatic rates for this kind of
algorithm we need to answer two
questions
the first question is about the inner
loop
what is the approximation error of the
leapfrog integration using the case
gradients
and the second question is about the
outer loop
can approximate all the solution uh
provided by the leapfrog integration
leads to small sampling arrow
okay so in the next few slides i will
answer these two questions by uh showing
you a very uh
clean and
uh
beautiful
sorry clean and simple analysis uh to
answer these two questions
so before that let me first lay out a
few assumptions which are very standard
assumption
uh the first function is f is the new
strongly uh convex which means uh the
target diffusion is uh
starting uh log concave
the second assumption is f is l smooth
which means the target diffusion is a
log
uh smooth and i denote this kappa which
is the ratio between ao and the mu
that's the condition number okay
and i also assume
the statistically an estimator has
bounded the furnace uh which is bounded
by a sigma square but for different
statistical reading estimators uh i will
show you that this sigma square can have
different dependence on on the for
example step size dimension and such and
such so which i will show you in a few
uh minutes
so the proof is based on the following
uh three uh sequences
the first sequence is the algorithm
sequence is a discrete time algorithm uh
i introduced some shorthand notation
uh this s eta which means
i just
wrong hmc with the class gradient with
steps as eta from q a then i get qk plus
one and similarly uh
when i apply this s eta to p k i will
obtain p k plus one so this is
essentially the the algorithm the
discrete time algorithm
the second sequence is the is the hmc
with conditionally expected gradient
okay so in other words
i define this g sub eta
notation when i apply this g sub eta
notation to q k
i will get this conditional
expectation of q k plus 1 conditional p
k and q k
and similarly when i apply this g sub
eta to p k
i
basically doing this conditional
expectation of p k plus one conditional
p can and q k
okay but this does not give you the full
gradient because in the leapfrog
integrator there are three steps and the
first step and the third step uh
involves the category
so the uh the catastrophe actually is a
nice tip so when you take a conditional
expectation it does not give you the
full gradient
and the last sequence is the the exact
the idealized hmc dynamic this is a
continuous time dynamic
and the goal uh for the inner loop
analysis is to bundle approximation
arrow
which is nothing but just the difference
between
the first sequence and the third
sequence
the second sequence is some auxiliary
sequence that we introduced to
each analysis
all right now uh let me define some
uh augmented uh variable z k we just
concatenate the position variable qp and
also the velocity uh variable pk
together and the pk is normalized by uh
uh squadron for l there is a muslims
parameter this is just the for the
purpose of
proving the
bounded uh expansion property so you can
think of there's a uh
they have a function uh where the
quadratic uh
norm is normalized by one and uh uh this
one over square root of l
okay and with a slight abuse of notation
i just use this same as a sub eta
operator
now i just applied it to both q and p
okay this is a slight abuse of notation
and from zero
if i apply this uh operator for k times
now i use this uh s sub eta super k uh
notation to uh to denote that i apply
this base eta operation for k times and
similarly i use the same notation no
convention for h and the g
operator
so this is a definition arrow
and first of all i subtract
and add back the same quantity so this
quantity
is starting from zero you wrong
k minus one step of
uh hmc with gradient
update
followed by one
another
hmc update but using the conditional
expected gradient so this is the meaning
of this
quantity
and based on conditional independence
this uh norm square expectation equal to
the summation of these two guys
and if we look at this term this term is
nothing but just the one step
statistical arrow between
the case gradient and the conditional
expanded gradient
uh i will choose k uh later okay on the
utah so i will choose the staff size
such that
even though there are some uh
coefficients which is a greater than one
but by choosing the step size i will
make that uh coaching there to be a
bigger one a constant so in that case
the approximation error will not grow as
k
growth
this index k takes the index of the
inner loop
yeah
so little analysis is still inside the
inner leapfrog
ingredient part
so this can be bounded by uh this order
l
one divided by l sigma square
eta square so sigma squared is the
foreign gradient ao is the smoothing's
parameter and the yield highest
step size
and this guy
by further
subtracting and adding another interning
and related quantity which is h eta s
sub eta came as one z zero so this guy
is you start from z zero you run
k minus one step of uh hmc uh with the
cat's gradient followed by another step
of hmc but using the integration the
exact update okay and then uh we are
using the young's inquiry to bound the
list term
uh by the summation of these two terms
and the notion of yang's inquiry we are
using is this
one plus alpha and the one plus one
divided by alpha fusion because we want
to have some additional uh degree of
freedom other to uh to bound this uh
quantity
okay
and then now let's take a closer look of
listen so listen
it is nothing but just the
discretization arrow because
you can see from ace some eta came as
one z zero from this point the same
point
if you do for example conditional
expected gradient update or if you do
the exact update so this is
something sort of the dissociation arrow
okay
and the remaining thing is a two bond
list
and in order to bond this term uh we can
uh fill these ten as starting from two
different points
there's a blue one and this right one
are denoted here
applying the same uh operator h eta okay
unfortunately we don't have a
contraction property for this h eta but
we have some
good enough property which is a bounded
expansion property for this h eat
operator so we can show that
the
expansion coefficient can be bounded by
e to the power 2 times square root of l
times eta
and using this property we can bound
this term
and by putting these several
pieces together
we will have
the approximation arrow
after k
leave a
frog integration
is up bounded by
this
expansion term
which depends on the approximation arrow
of the k minus one step of the fraud
equation by using status gradient plus
this
uh one step arrow which is the sum of
the one step approximation arrow and
also
a one step statical arrow and also one
step uh displacation error
okay
and using some uh
very simple inequality we can move this
one uh plus alpha into the excitement of
this exponential function
and now we need to choose alpha because
alpha is the parameter we introduced
when we apply the young's inequality so
here we need to choose alpha we choose
alpha to be in the same order of this
guy
and then
we choose
k times eta because k times eta appears
in the example of the
exponential function in the numerator
but we want this numerator to be a
bigger one right so we choose k eta is
less than or equal to
1 divided by square root of l
and in this way we can make this
numerator uh to be a constant
and also we just
divide it by a list term by the
denominator we do some simplification
then we get this arrow so this is an
approximation arrow after big k number
of uh the frog uh integration with a
sketch gradient uh it doesn't depend on
tape so this is a the thing we want to
this is the bond we want to attain
because if we depend on k then the iron
will
explode
any question
okay
now uh we have the approximation arrow
bound for the inner loop
uh i will talk about the uh
convergence for the outer loop and the
convergence for automatically is based
on some contractive
contraction property approved by chennai
and
uh
santosh in their very nice paper so we
basically consider these two uh markov
chains and we are doing some kind of a
coupling so each element in this
hmc which is the test gradient
microchip is just
the initial sample
and the sample after the first inner
loop the sample after the second in the
loop so this is the first trend and the
other trend is just the idealized hmc
every time you just
initialize it from the sample from the
target distribution okay
and using this a nice contraction
property
but i want to
comment that this property when you use
it you'll be careful because it only
holds for any two points
with different uh station but with the
same uh velocity
so this
uh contracting probably does not hold
for any q p or q prime t prime so the
velocity needs to be the same
okay we have this contraction and then
we uh further apply another
young's inequality and combining this
uh underneath something arrow by at
least a contraction arrow as well as the
approximation error we proved uh in the
inner loop analysis okay
and then uh with some parameter choice
we are able to prove this uh main result
so this is a the convergence rate of the
cast gradient hmc for any uh static
gradient estimator with boundary
difference uh sigma square
sigma square here okay
and now let me showcase some
applications of this
uh general uh result when we apply it to
different surcharge gradient estimators
uh so we haven't tried two mini batches
because gradient or we can apply it to
uh asurg which is a foreign seduced the
catholic estimator or this is the kaiser
average ingredient called sago
uh all controversial gradient due to
time limit i will just focus on the
first two and uh for the remaining
result you can find it in the paper so
when you buy this category i don't think
i need to introduce it everyone uh knows
it you just a sample subset of data
points and calculates gradient on that
subset
and for svig it's a very
nice algorithm
so there's a
this is actually a epoch wise uh update
so the epoch lens is a bigger n so after
a bigger number of
samples you will saw that sample as a
reference sample and use the full
gradient of that reference sample as a
reference gradient
and we see in the epoch
or between any two reference points you
are going to calculate this so-called
semi-stick test gradient which is the
difference between two mini bags that
has gradient at the current sample and
the reference sample and then you pass
the full gradient at the reference
sample so you can show that this is a
semi uh stochastic gradient first of all
it's unbiased
second the furnace actually will
decrease when the distribution of qk and
q2 getting closer and closer to each
other
and
based on the assumptions i
laid out before we can show that the
difference of mini batch has gradient
it's bounded by
n square is the number of other savings
divided by b b is limited by size
times some quantity which is the
expectation of the
uh each individual uh gradient
gradient of each individual function at
x star exercise the global minimum of
the
negative log density uh function
and for ac rg actually we can show that
the reference can be bounded by l square
divided by b
and times n square d and the eta square
so let's earn remember that this big
earning is the lines of the epoch in a
strategy
okay
now uh
we can also calculate the variance
boundary for other two for the other two
student gradient estimators which i just
omitted here and by substituting this uh
foreign bond into the
this master statement and then do some
calculation uh we can prove the query
capacity of
uh stochastic gradient hmc
with different kinds of categories and
estimators including mini batch
surcase gradient or ferns boost stick
has gradient or controverid
gradient
and
you can say that
if i use inference reduced success
gradient the query complexity
the number of queries to the
gradient of each fi so this is
considered as one card so the query
capacity actually has a sub-linear
dependence on the number of uh
observations it's like n2 uh two divided
by three
and also the epsilon the something arrow
also has a sublinear dependence uh like
one divided by epsilon uh two divided by
three okay
and you can do a more careful uh
comparison for example with a foreign
introduced uh overdumped
uh
landing high dynamic which is undivided
by epsilon but in terms of dependence on
both
n and epsilon actually our result is
strictly better
so
this is a something i want to
talk about
and in the next five minutes i will just
show that a similar analysis can be
applied to on the damped landing pad
dynamic actually we did this work
three years ago at that time the proof
technique we use is slightly different
and
it's more complicated but now using the
same
uh
proof roadmap we can simplify the proof
a lot
and uh
uh which gives
you some
easy to follow analysis
so remind you so this underlying
language is a sde i just introduced
before
and for internet or we can partially
solve this sde to generate the some kind
of
uh
implementable dynamic
and the key uh here is we need to
replace the full gradient better uh the
kaiser gradient and this uh introduce
some changes when you
prove the convergence
but we can follow the same uh proof
roadmap we introduce three sequences and
here i want to comment that the second
sequence the auxiliary sequence which is
the conditional expected gradient in
this case actually it is equal to the
exact gradient
because
uh in longer down line you can find the
cat gradient there's only one step
that's cascading in each iteration
okay and we can do similar uh sampling
arrow decomposition which i'm not going
to
uh repeat uh here
but uh
uh but i want to mention that this ck
actually you'll need to define it in a
slightly different way so this decay is
a contamination of xk
and xk plus vk this is also shown in
international paper because they found
that by constructing this kind of
augmented uh
parameter uh you can have some
reactional function that will lead to
contraction
compared with hmc the nice thing about
the underdog landing one is that the
contraction property uh proved by
tornado hold for any two points z and v
prime
okay but before you remember that in hmc
the contraction probably only holds four
i need to pawn with different positions
but the same uh velocity okay
and because of this
it will also simplify
the analysis in some steps
and let me directly show the main result
we proved
the reference is the 2018 xml paper and
also
strategy at all they also have some
results for control florida on the
diamond landing fan and i believe in
china at all people they also have the
mini badge
version
but uh
the result will prove that using the new
technique
gives us exactly the same results
but in this result we have proved uh
using some different more complicated
one uh several years ago
so you can see that we're just plugging
those furnace bound into this master
theorem and then we can
derive the current capacity for
underdone the launching fund with
stakeholders
and the interesting observation is you
can just compare
line by line for example statistics
gradient
uh on the damped launching time which is
gradient hamiltonian montano so they
have the same query uh complexity and
also for astrology or saga on the damped
landing fan
and the fzrg or saga hmc they have the
same query capacity
of course in terms of dependence on the
condition number there may be some
minor difference because we didn't try
to sharpen the dependence on the
collision number because in all uh
result capacity result we treat kappa as
a bigger one as a constant okay
all right so
to summarize
we provide a unified analysis for hmc
and the underdamped landing fund
with the kaiser gradients
and the analysis is based on three
sequences of markov chains
and
something i already mentioned is
when you
utilize the contraction property of hmc
and under them landing line
they are different in terms of
either you know called for any two
points or however i need to point with
the same velocity and also the
contraction probably hold at a different
level for another landing right hold for
every uh iteration but for hmc uh the
contracting property only holds in every
k iteration so only holds in the outer
loop rather than the inner loop
and what's next so one thing i think
might be interesting to look at is
uh if the target distribution is not
uh
strongly log concave or even log concave
for example non-lock concave in that
case the contraction property does not
hold and how to control approximation
error of this kind of a numerical solver
could be an interesting uh problem to
think about so there are some prior work
by rajin ki and uh franklin webster and
many other
people
they relaxed the
contraction uh to be a weaker version
based on log super if you call the upon
query uh in korean such as subject and
another direction is at the beginning i
mentioned that i removed the the
metropolis hasting crashing step because
i don't know how to
come up with a psychiatric version or
statistical estimate for the uh
rejection or acceptance uh probability
but in global talks in this workshop i
see if using some very kind of idea to
conduct a
nearly unbiased estimator of the
metropolis hasting probability so that
might be an interesting thing to think
about if we can combine
this metabolism staff with the current
uh statistical gradient hours
so that's all i want to talk about thank
you for your attention
uh thank you chainsaw for a nice talk
are there any questions
is your analysis tight for some of the
svrg variants
i mean the stochastic gradient variants
so for example the n to the two third
over epsilon to the two thirds yeah we
believe uh it is a tight because uh if
we are uh familiar with the results for
convex optimization using srg there are
this kind of dependence also
showing up
but
but
the key training is here that uh
something from strongly law concave
diffusion in optimization there is for
example nestle accelerated gradient also
called accelerated base rg or kachosa
some kind of algorithm which can give
you a brighter
gradient capacity result so it's
possible that if we are not using
astrology by using some
accelerated version of
srg we might be able to
reduce the
dependence that this
dependence on the number of
observations so that's i think it's a
possible
[Music]
thanks for the very interesting talk so
i know hong kong you have also looked
into second order methods uh for other
applications do you think that this uh
you know variance reduce second orders
or
just generally like second order
approach would work better here
that's a great question so i also talked
to someone during this workshop
because of for second order optimization
if a function is for example
non-convex but if you are using let's
say cubic regularization you are still
guaranteed to find the for example local
minimum if the function satisfy hygiene
dips is a property
and i know in the something literature
the hygiene division probably is often
also assumed in many uh papers
but i'm not sure
what's the correspondence of uh
escaping from saddle point or finding a
local me what's the corresponding part
in something this is something i haven't
fully
uh
uh understand myself maybe someone knows
you can teach me but i don't know what's
the correspondence of escaping settle
pond in the sampling uh process in
optimization we know we want to find a
local minimum or even global minimum we
if we hit a saddle point
we can use the negative curvature
direction to escape from that saddle
point using either cubic regularization
or using some like perturbed uh green
method but in sampling if we we already
have some for example running mode
which is also kind of a random uh
foundation and with that uh random
publication
uh plays some role in terms of escaping
the cyto
and what's the meaning of escaping the
saddle in something is it still
meaningful
or is it
well defined so this is something i i
don't know quite
i don't have a good understanding so i'm
happy to discuss with you offline or
yeah yeah yeah
any other question
[Music]
maybe i have one so um earlier this week
so chin li gave a talk about a
coordinate using instead of the full
gradient taking uh
you know sampling coordinates
and i was wondering how does the
analysis that you present here compared
to the the work of chin lee and and
steve wright
uh
are you familiar with that i think at a
high level it should be uh similar but
all work is uh
in 2018 earlier so uh and
yeah i i need to take a closer look of
their proof but i believe this kind of
foreign production technique
the proof should
uh share a lot of uh similarity okay but
their pharma induction is not
in the
sample dimension actually it's in the
coordinate dimension so
there might be uh
from a different angle so
uh i need to take a closer look before i
i can tell you the exact difference yeah
thank you
so let's thank the speaker again
thank you
then we resume at four o'clock